rub up your engines today I'm going to
show you how you can save money if you
need to get another key for your car now
in the olden days between 1994 there are
just simple keys then we're caught you
could go to hardware store and get one
made for a couple of bucks
but that's not the case anymore this
newer Toyota has a key that you can open
the doors and things with and it's got
an immobilizer chip inside so it will
only start if it has the chip and some
modern keys like this one for a 2015
Chrysler you don't have a key it's a
remote that you just walk in the car
with and you push your button to start
the car these things can cost a lot of
money if they break or you lose them so
as you as you want to show you how to
save money if you have one that has an
immobilizer chip and has box that open
and close it you can go ahead and buy
one of these things online often there
is little less fifteen to thirty dollars
then go to a locksmith where they can
cut the keys so it will unlock the door
and so it'll actually start the car when
you turn it now if where does it sounds
I have a machine that can do that
programming but I'm an independent
mechanic and only bonded locksmiths
or dealership mechanics can get access
to the code so even though I have a
machine I can't call them myself and if
you ever lose the fob for this keyless
entry system it's gonna cost you a lot
of money to get another one made which
is why you always want to have at least
two of these things if you don't and you
bought a car use get another one made at
a locksmith put it in a drawer where you
know it's safe so you know you'll always
have a good one you go to a locksmith
and save a ton of money because of
course the locksmiths are gonna charge
you a lot less than a dealer for making
one of these keyless fobs or the key
with a chip in it and if you lose the
keyless fob system be sure to find a
good locksmith because I had a customer
with a 2012 Prius they lost the key and
the dealer charged them 567 dollars to
make a new key and reprogram but when I
had another customer lose their key in a
Prius I sent him to my locksmith who
travels he came to his house so he
didn't have to tow the car there and his
whole bit
I was 283 dollars instead of 567 dollars
quite a difference just make sure you
get a good bond at locksmith who
understands modern technology because
over the years I've tried various ones
and some on there were complete buffoons
that had no idea what they were doing
and then that case when they came to my
shop and said oh they could do it for
150 bucks and they tried for an hour and
they said oh we can't get it to work I
said well I'm not paying you one cent
you said you could do it you couldn't so
you gotta find a good locksmith to have
this done so really if you have a
keyless system or a key system that has
a chip inside it take my advice
go to a good locksmiths if you don't
have two of each and buy another one and
store it somewhere where you remember
where it is so you never have to worry
about starting from scratch with a brand
new key system more quick fixes on the
Scotty Kilmer Channel